[Music]
foreign
professor of marketing at the Stanford
Graduate School of Business and I'm
Barry Ryan a lecturer at the GSB we
teach a course called the fundamentals
of effective selling here are five key
takeaways from our course
[Music]
effective sales is about Discovery we
need to learn what is important to a
customer we need to learn about that
negative consequences of the customer's
current situation and understand the
customer's thinking about what might
constitute an ideal solution
with this information we can drive a
wedge that is create a stark contrast
between the customer's current situation
and their ideal and then map our product
onto the customer's ideal solution
it turns out that many people are
reluctant to ask questions or they just
haven't been trained to ask effective
questions instead of being curious they
make assumptions without exploring the
points of view expressed by the customer
learning to be authentically curious is
critical for Effective selling
now you don't get good at sales by
reading a book I have over 35 years of
experience as a sales trainer and
consultant and I am firmly convinced
that effective selling comes from skills
that can be learned but that must be
practice while MBA students are
accustomed to learning by reading books
and analyzing case studies my Approach
leans much more heavily on small group
exercises and lots of role plays for
example we have students create a
value-based prospecting script that they
will use when cold calling prospects the
students learn by presenting to each
other and discussing what is effective
but in the end they come away with ideas
of how they would do things differently
our goal is to help the students develop
the confidence they need to apply all
selling skills a lot of sales comes down
to getting the answer to these two
questions is there a real deal here and
can we get a deal done
please
the process used in sales to get the
answers to these two questions is called
qualification
we can use questions such as where does
this project fall on your list of key
business priorities in order to get some
insight into whether the customer is
serious about a deal
but when it comes to understanding how
to get a deal done it is absolutely
essential to understand a customer's
decision-making process
effective salespeople know that each
customer has a unique set of steps they
go through in deciding on a course of
action it's like the hurdles in track
and field in which a runner has to clear
a number of obstacles in order to reach
the Finish Line it's the job of sales to
use curiosity to identify each hurdle
and discover what it will take to clear
each obstacle successfully and move on
to the next stage
[Music]
now students might get nervous about the
prospect of closing a deal because they
may fear rejection or because they're
just unsure how to close a sale we know
closing is just being curious about how
to get a deal then now to help them get
more comfortable we put them through a
series of role play exercises in which
one student the sales rep tries to close
the deal and another student the
customer raises objections
instead of thinking of an objection as
an obstacle that needs to be overcome or
beaten down we encourage the students to
think of an objection really as a gift
it's an opportunity to understand the
customer's thinking and discover what
might stand in the way of getting a deal
done
[Music]
most of our students say that they don't
intend to go into a traditional sales
role and yet they take our class because
they're convinced that the process and
the skill set will be useful in all
types of selling contexts
for example aspiring entrepreneurs are
essentially selling their ideas to
investors we've heard many success
stories from students who have used a
curiosity based approach to fundraising
and students looking for an employment
opportunity are essentially selling
themselves they can use a curiosity
based process to learn about a company
discover an executive's priorities and
really create the ideal job where none
existed
learning and practicing curiosity based
selling can help anyone further their
vision and accomplish their goals
[Music]
you know Barry and I are so
complementary you like to fish well you
don't but you're going to like a lot
more fishing I think Barry could get me
out fishing I'd look forward to that
what about motorcycle riding or ATV in
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign